[Music]
[Quynh Nguyen, PhD] This particular project,
funded by the National Library of Medicine,
is producing a new national data resource for
built environment characteristics using
Google Street View images and computer vision
models and to estimate the association
between built environment characteristics
and health outcomes on a national level.
[Ming Hu] Built environment, in the simplest
way, is just everything human built.
It includes the streets, all
the buildings, all the houses.
[Thu Nguyen] We merged the Google
Street View image data with the patientdata.
So we looked at coronary artery
disease, hypertension, and diabetes.
And then our model controlled for individual
characteristics such as like race, ethnicity,
insurance status, English language ability.
[Quynh Nguyen] In our pilot study, we merged
those indicators with patient data in Utah.
It was close to a million patient records.
Healthcare systems want to know - what are
some exposures that their patients encounter?
What are some of the predictors that can help
them better understand where's the
chronic risk disease coming from?
[Thu Nguyen] We found that like greeners
of streets or visible wires or dilapidatedbuildings
predicted prevalence of coronary
artery disease and hypertension diabetes.
[Quynh Nguyen] So crosswalk and sidewalks
are indicators of walkability. So the more
walkable neighborhood is, the more
it encourages physical activity.
We have other indicators like street trees
and street greenery which promote,
which we found are associated with, lower
obesity and better mental health.
We made a geoportal where you can select the
neighborhood feature that you're interested in.
You can also zoom into a location. So you can
type in address or a city and it'll naturally
zoom in and give you the distribution of
the characteristics at that neighborhood.
People can interact with the data.
It allows for a quick analyses,
flexible boundaries, and publicly available.
[Thu Nguyen] And it's a huge data source for for
the public health researchers and policy makers.
[Ming Hu] Doing this way, it can give us
first, a set of large data to show us what is the impact
of the building we design and we build.
[Quynh Nguyen] Without NLM support,
we wouldn't have the protected
time that we had over five years.
We wouldn't be able to purchase
the images and also purchase the
the computing software and
hardware to run the models,
and also the granted help support - doctoral
students - and fund their their entire studies.
It takes a significant amount
of time to walk and inventory
neighborhood features of the built environment.
And so that would not be possible if you
are interested in any place across the U.S.
And thus, we need computer vision
and Google Street View images to
enable the analyses at the national level.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]
[Silence]